if you look over here we can see some
typical aerials now this aerial here
which you might just be able to see is a
so-called dielectric aerial which is
which is designed for Bluetooth
applications and so the wavelengths will
be quite long but we've played it in
tricks in the design stage use some
dielectric material and we've ended up
with an area which is just a few
millimeters long
so as we walk along I guess you see
aerials everywhere on the top seven
roofs of almost every building well we
can see we can see a mobile phone mast
on the top of the hospital we we
certainly depend on them almost for our
routine daily life from everything from
from mobile phone of course mobile
phones there we are everybody everybody
knows what they are this is the back of
the physics building and if you if you
look at the you see the dome of the
ordinary conventional reflector optical
telescope but today we're a little bit
more interested in how these different
aerials work this is the radio telescope
system a single radio telescope dish a
radio wave comes in here flat parallel
hits this curved surface and then
bounces off to the focus which is the
aerial here so the only aerial in the
system is inside that little that that
little shield there this this aerial is
tuned to around about 1.4 gigahertz so
that's much higher than the normal radio
transmissions that we were used to
hearing but around about this sort of
mobile phone transmission area what this
is actually looking at is is the natural
emissions from hydrogen now if I was to
hold a bucket of hydrogen here in front
of the aerial we wouldn't see anything
at all we wouldn't pick that signal up
because what what we're looking for is
very very rare spin flip events in the
in the hydrogen itself and that that is
so rare that we would never be able to
detect it here on earth but when you've
got a galaxy right out there with
billions and billions of tons of
hydrogen gas then that's enough for
these rare events
become quite a large signal well this
racket I've been trying to receive for
my radio station and I appear to be
getting lots of crackles on my on my
radio safe I hope you couldn't hope to
compare them put them there they never
microphone there now where that where
they're coming from I've got a good idea
let's go and find out
[Applause]
getting louder
[Applause]
just approve it you see it went well
what's going on in this this piece of
kit we've we've got a some power
supplies so the electrons are piling up
on this on this little tip over here and
then when the voltage is high enough for
the for the air to break down just like
in a under storm in a lightning strike
then the electrons will jump across
across that gap just for a moment this
is this is a single electron if I have
if I have a charge then that produces an
electric field which radiates out but
probably where you're standing Brady you
probably wouldn't be able to pick up
that electric field from from there if
if my electron is traveling at a
constant velocity from one end of the
tube to the other
we call that an electric current now of
course I'm going to be in trouble from
my physics colleagues because a real
electron doesn't travel that far and it
travels a few microns
perhaps in a metal but this is a good
enough in this is a good illustration so
what does that do well a produces a
current of course and because the
current is flowing that produces a
magnetic field around that but that
isn't enough that isn't that isn't going
to produce radiated wave what what
produces the the wave is when the
electrons start to oscillate up and down
so we have an alternating frequency or
we could call that an acceleration so in
the spark gap we had our electrons
pretty much stationary on one side of
the one side of the gap and then
suddenly whoop their accelerated over
the gap
so when you've got an accelerated charge
you've got not only the electric field
radially but you also got an electric
field tangentially along the along the
area like that and it's the combination
of those two effects the magnetic field
and the tangential field which produces
the relationship the orthogonal
relationship between the magnetic and
the electric field that couples to this
traveling wave what happens at the other
end is let's say we've got our we've got
our aerial we've got an aerial here
that's just a just a piece of wire and
inside that wire we've got we've got
stationary conduction electrons when a
wave comes in from our transmitter it's
not very good because I'm moving anyway
when the wave comes in literally it
makes those it makes those electrons
move in sympathy and of course that is a
that means that there is a voltage at
the the base of the aerial which I can
then then pick up with the electronics
and the receiver inside there okay so
why why are aerials a certain size and
we've got a you have an FM type of
aerial and we tuned it to local radio
station which is say say 100 megahertz
then we'd expect the wavelength to of
that of that wave to be 3 meters and
sometimes we refer to wavelengths in in
meters radio waves can can occupy a
variety of of wavelengths we only have
to look at our radio dial the seldom
used long wave of course is literally
means long wave and so radio for long
wave is actually 1,500 meters long so
what does that that's 3 and 3/4 route
times around the running track so that's
how long the wave length is when we get
to our FM wave band which is around
about a hundred megahertz 100 million
oscillations of that little table tennis
ball
a per second then the wavelengths come
down to around about 2 or 3 meters so
what's 2 or 3 meters that sort of length
okay and so the best aerial we actually
can build is when we have a quarter
wavelength so when that's a quarter
wavelength long we get a good a good
antenna however when we go up in
frequency we start talking about our
mobile phone type of aerials which are a
couple of gigahertz so that's two
thousand million cycles per second then
the aerials can be probably a little bit
smaller so probably the wavelengths are
10 centimeters and so we get aerials
which are perhaps a couple of couple of
centimeters however we can play a few
little extra tricks because you can't
see an aerial on this on this phone and
in point of fact by slowing the wave in
a so called dielectric just like a
refractive index optically then we can
play a few tricks we can make we can
actually make our aerial effectively
smaller by surrounding it in a block of
dielectric like a plastic in a sense you
look over here we can see some typical
aerials now this aerial here which you
might just be able to see is a so-called
dielectric aerial which is which is
designed for Bluetooth applications and
so the wavelengths will be quite long
but we've played it some tricks in the
design stage use some dielectric
material and we've ended up with an
aerial which is just a few millimeters
long this is a patch antenna which is
used for Global Positioning System
antenna so that works at about
one-and-a-half gigahertz and the actual
aerial is this square plate of of
conductor on the top well those are so
small and that's quite good otherwise
our aerials on our mobile phones would
be bigger than the phone which of course
if you're old enough like me
and remember the first mobile phones of
course they were